[Musik]
in der korona krise schlägt die stunde
der wissenschaft und die stunde der
mythen kurde verschwörungs mythen machen
im internet die runde das virus sei
biologische kriegsführung der planet
können mit massen meditation
desinfiziert werden corona sei die rache
der gebeutelten natur in zeiten der
pandemie zeigt sich auch wie unvernunft
grassiert war das früher auch schon so
möchte ich von der medizin historikerin
martina king wissen und woher kommen
diese ganzen verschwörungs mythen das
kläre ich mit religionswissenschaftler
michael blume schön sind sie beide
herzlich willkommen
die einen behaupten dass gefährliche
corona virus sei als biowaffe in einem
chinesischen labor gezielt und geplant
und freigesetzt worden
alles finanziert von george soros einem
amerikanischen milliardär jüdischer
abstammung andere glauben das sei das
neue mobilfunknetz 5g welches das virus
verursacht und verbreite wieder andere
sind überzeugt dass der multimilliardär
und microsoft gründer bill gates als
drahtzieher hinter dem corona virus
stecke er wolle damit die
bevölkerungszahl kontrollieren
das klingt für mich tatsächlich alles so
surreal dass sich an der menschlichen
urteilskraft zweifel wie geht es ihnen
denn damit fucking ja also ich denke
dass es nicht generalisieren natürlich
sind solche pandemische abnehmer zeiten
der ungleichheit und ungleichheit
gesellschaftliche ungleichheit
produziert natürlich verschwörungen vor
allem gegen eliten die unter die nicht
privilegierten haben den eindruck die
eliten könnten autorität wie sie
gewinnen wir die seuche wird das ist
etwas was das in der frühen neuzeit gibt
in der späteren neuzeit selbst der
spanische grippe war dass man auf 1
auftauchen immer die idee die eliten die
führungsfiguren wollen uns vergiften tun
und was ins essen um die bevölkerung zu
dezimieren und so weiter darüber einer
seite
darüber sprechen wir ganz klar noch auf
die über diese ungleichverteilung war
sie auch herr blum
in bezug auf urteilskraft die man
anzweifelt wie stehen sie dazu
also einerseits sehe ich dass wir diese
verschwörung mythen die dateien stark
haben das geht schon los im januar und
ist jetzt hier zb in deutschland auch
sehr eskaliert mit naidoo
der vorwurf dass ein satanskult aus dem
extertal der film herstellt ist schon
sehr abgefahren
auf der anderen seite muss ich ja sagten
wir haben das auf dem herzkatheter
geschichte immer wieder und wir haben
facebook ohne wir hatten
geißler und wenn wir das in den
vergleich setzt muss man sagen das war
früher heftiger
also es gibt es heute ist im internet
sehr stark aber im vergleich zu früher
ist auch zb die gewaltbereitschaft
einfach niedriger von denen er wirklich
sagen ja wir sonst dem stellen dass der
mensch nicht nur rational ist aber wir
werden diesmal auch schlauer sein als
ich freue mich trotzdem ist denn in
krisenzeiten wo ebenso auch ihr
rationales verhalten wie sie es jetzt
beide auch schon angedeutet haben nun
ähnlich anfällig dafür ist zieht man
dann schon eine tendenz vom locker
zurück zum mythos
ja auf jeden fall also krise nach das
löste bedeutungs bedarf
das kann ja auch ein positiver sein
sagte gott prüft ob ihr herz haben ob
wir sonst war ich sind wir fertig sind
oder für die natur quasi das bringt uns
dazu nachzudenken ob das macht richtig
wie es mit der massentierhaltung oder so
also man kann ja unterschiedlich darauf
reagieren und menschen reagieren darf
unterschiedlich aber es ist natürlich so
dass man viel tatsächlich dann glauben
die grundschüler stecken dahinter
und das verstärkt natürlich ist also das
hilft dann auch nichts reise dann das
gefühl danach redet die welt besser
sondern sie tauschen ein im schein
erklärung die in einem gefühl der angst
und bedrohung angst bedrohung und
tatsächlich vom logo her zurück zum
mythos ist denn angst ganz oft wirklich
der aus der auslöser für solche
mythen fragt ihn ja ohne zweifel also
wie ich schon vorher gesagt habe wenn
man in der solchen geschichte
zurückschaut dann ist es ja tatsächlich
so dass menschen unmittelbar vom tod
bedroht waren und vor allem die die sich
in ungünstigen gesellschaftlichen
kulturellen lebens bedingungen fanden
und diese sollten konnten in keiner
weise gemanagt werden es gibt erst im
zwanzigsten jahrhundert und dann 20 der
100 möglichkeiten das solchen dämmung so
dass die blanke angst die panik
sozusagen immer eine vitale war und
natürlich schon erklärt warum sich
besonders verschwörung wie gesagt gegen
die führungseliten wendet
herr blume sie nicken ja also es ist so
dass das judentum war die erste religion
die in alphabet schrift geschrieben
wir haben die bildungsexpansion wir
haben sehr früh gegen ghana monikas
denken jüdische ärzte die auch an den
höfen sinn von muslim oder von christen
und deswegen so ist für diese
verschwörungstheorie dann halt auch
magrat juden stecken damit dritter da
gesagt die während ohne vergifte rahmen
und die und diejenigen die sind alle sie
kontrollieren das ist es daneben job
steckt dahinter und jeder und co
das heißt also tatsächlich ist das vom
mythologischen er kam nicht neu dass da
werden immer wieder die alten wie neu
aufgekocht und verlierer ist das
tatsächlich so zu sagen da kann man viel
hoffnung geschickte lernen nur noch
einmal der unterschied
ich denke heute haben wir zumindest in
europa stabile recht starten
wir haben ein höheres bildungsniveau
also dass jetzt ein probe stattfinden
darunter dass geißler sich die in sich
selber auspeitschen halte ich für
unwahrscheinlich was wir aber schon
haben sind vereinzelte fälle von gewalt
die wird es auch sich angekommen monaten
ich möchte ein bisschen besser verstehen
weshalb überhaupt solche mythen zustande
kommen ist es denn einfach so dass der
mensch nicht
mit der irritation des unverständlichen
umzugehen dass er immer wieder musste
versucht zu produzieren und in die welt
legt und sich alles so erklärt oder
deswegen werden wir verschwörungs mieten
sie haben sie auch gesagt es sind alte
elemente in diesen mythen die immer
wieder belebt werden weshalb ist das so
weil uns die welt sowohl im großen wie
auch im kleinen natürlich was überhaupt
übersteigt also wir vereinfachen wir
müssen vereinfacht die stadt in unserem
leben mensch der wissenschaft den ärzten
und weiteren leider der schweiz der
bundesrepublik um eine damit natürlich
immer ganz komplexe gebilde das heißt
wir müssen die welt zusammen fassen wir
müssen sie greifbar machen und das tun
wir über mythen und symbole und da gibt
es ganz arg positive sagen
menschenrechte abgeschrieben oder zählen
aber wir wissen was damit gemeint ist
was da keinen sex geschichten verbunden
ist es gibt dabei immer auch
angstbesetzte negativ
also ich würde sagen wird ist
tatsächlich etwas was normal ist dass
menschen in krisensituationen sich nach
dem sinn fragen nach deutschland fragen
und was den positiv ist aber dass man
sehen kann dass bildung und weiter doch
auch diese wirkung hat auf der anderen
seite erinnert uns einfach das internet
anbietet halt doch homo sapiens und die
die schicht der vernunft auch nicht so
dick wie man sich das wünschen würde
also drei haben bereits aber die
richtung die richtung entsteht was mich
interessiert sie unterscheiden ja herr
blume zwischen verschwörungstheorien und
verschwörungs mythen besser gesagt sie
sprechen nicht von verschwörungstheorien
erklären sie mal was steckt dahinter
ja also verschwörungs gläubige vor allem
an diesem der verschwörungstheorie weil
es gibt ihnen sozusagen schaffen die
hand ist handlich jobs haben sich
verbündet ist bill gates um die
weltbevölkerung zu verrichten
das ist jetzt meine themen will jetzt
widerlegt
natürlich sind zu den wissenschaften die
übrigen ganz anders die brauchen wenige
und die müssen die überprüfbar sein
und deswegen ist der begriff
verschwörungstheorie da schon mal
problematisch auch die funktion ist eine
ganz andere
wenn mir jemand sagt die jugend in einer
rasse und ich darauf hinweise dass das
nicht stimmt dass man zum beispiel zum
judentum übertreten kann oder dass wir
nur und jugend aller hautfarben haben
dann würde jetzt ein wissenschaftler
sagen ok damit ist das so die theorie
widerlegt wieder auch etwas anderes aber
ein verschwörungs leute übertragen
sie sind doch selber wird teil der
verschwörung sie müssen das wir fahren
das heißt man kann sozusagen
verschwörungs erzählungen in dem sinne
der auch nicht
letzter punkt wenn man sagt
verschwörungstheorie
dann sagen die leute gerne a also wenn
du nichts versucht theorie die dominanz
dann behauptest du ja es gibt überhaupt
gar keine verschwörungen und das stimmt
natürlich nicht also es gibt natürlich
in deutschland sind abgangs motoren
manipuliert worden und ähnliches und
genau dafür haben wir einen rechtsstaat
haben wir gewaltenteilung haben wir
schon medien haben die parlamente um
echte verschwörungen aufzudecken und
aber nicht sich zu verlieren
also ich verstehe dass sie wollen dem
auch das gewicht quasi neben durch den
begriff oder durch die unterscheidung
von king was halten sie denn davon jetzt
auch als historikerin in bezug auf
diesen begriff mythos der da jetzt
belastet wird ja ich fand eben nur stadt
geben
das verstört ich kann niemals als
wissenschaftlerin nur hin zu finden dass
ich ihm meine pflicht dass
verschwörungstheorien natürlich
begründungspflicht ich sind und das
waren sie nie und deswegen könnte man
von mythos reden das finde ich nicht so
nahe legen weil sich dann wird es
einfach mit einer ganz bestimmten form
der fiktionalen erzählung verbindet ich
finde man kann von verschwörungs
erzählungen reden die decken es
eigentlich ziemlich gut ab wie können
erfunden sein oder einen wahren kern
haben
ich würde gerne noch auf eine andere
sache hinweisen weil es ist immer heißt
vom logos zur mythos und man nicht außer
acht lassen sollte dass es dass solche
nach den weg aller song bahnen und das
haben sie derartig häufig
in der geschichte getan das ist glaube
ich genauso und systematisches musste
ist wie dieses vom range von der
rationalität zu funden erzählung sondern
genau andersrum einsehen genau große
solchen zwischen 19 jahrhundert ist es
vor allem die cholera haben im grunde
genommen die ganz große bewegung einer
rationalen cnc fischen public health
medizin angestoßen das beginnt mit dem
sogenannten englischen seine technologie
in der ersten ko- japan unter 32
dann setzt sich in großbritannien als
erstes die epidemiologische statistik
durch ohne die dortige statistik will in
fahrt zum beispiel hätten wir die
zahlungsmöglichkeiten und damit der
fassade des tracking alles gar nicht und
dann gibt es so etwas wie die
internationalen konferenzen zur
bekämpfung der cholera frage das sind
vorformen oder sind die ersten normen
wissenschaftler zusammenkünften im
neunzehnten jahrhundert die sich
gemeinsam einer bekämpfung einer
pandemie widmen also das sind nicht
einzelne figuren sondern ist es doch
eine ganz große bewegung vermieters zum
logos die gipfelt in der im
paradigmenwechsel der medizinischen
bakteriologie auf den wir als gesamt
heute noch sitzen und davon profitieren
und das ohne die quellen im grunde
genommen also weiß nicht ob es ohne die
nette die cholera wählen kann man sagen
haben das angestoßen und darf man die
rationalisierungs kraft von solchen die
es natürlich auch zu basteln schon gibt
wirklich nicht unterschätzen
das ist sehr spannend wie kommen spät
sein das machen wir ja auch entspannende
visierten also diese versehen da auch
die fraktionen reaktionen und
gleichzeitig betrachten wenn sie
wissenschaftlich und ganz vielen
zuschauern zuschauer interessieren sich
das heißt also wir selber sind auch
halten dieses prozesses wir nehmen daher
guck mal was es dafür verschiedene
reaktionen sind einige finden wir sind
alle ganz furchtbar
das heißt wir rationalisieren das und
ich will es also aus zu sehen es gibt
dann jedes mal einen doppelten schub
also natürlich war es eigentlich
wichtigen bedeutung
natürlich auch in den wissenschaften
schub nach vorne und lage eben auch dass
das interesse daran wirklichkeit ist
menschen wollen verstehen warum leute in
so etwas verrücktes glauben oder warum
sie zum beispiel den onkel haben und mit
dem man wohl noch reden konnte in der 40
abdreht schon sagen das ist ein auf
wissenschaftliches wir kommen später
noch auf dieses side effects oder dann
backlash ist quasi auch die dass die das
hat so solche pandemien ich möchte
vorerst noch etwas in die runde werfen
nämlich hat in den letzten wochen ist
ein video kursiert von der comicserie
und us-amerikanische die simpsons das
zeigen ja die frage stellt sie natürlich
im internet haben die simpsons wieder
mal wie nach der wahl von kramp die
zukunft vorausgesagt und hier wird er
das ganze so ein bisschen humor ii sieht
man kann darüber lachen tatsächlich aber
gibt es jahr verschwörungs mythen die
sagen dass die us-regierung dieses virus
gezüchtet habe um die wirtschaft chinas
lahm zu legen sind das typische deutung
smeaton einer globalisierten welt fragt
ihn einerseits vielleicht ja das kann
ich nicht beurteilen weil ich historiker
bin was ich beurteilen kann ist diese
patienten humor denn der entscheidenden
dem clip ist ja dass das eine satire auf
verschwörungstheorien ist und nicht die
verschwörungstheorie selber und die
jungs theorien dass man also mit der
armeen vernichten kann sind als
bestandteil der sogenannten b zellen
komik seit etwa 1890 im kulturellen
gedächtnis wirklich ziemlich tief
verankert gibt auch umfeld des ersten
weltkriegs schon einerseits die idee
dass man also bio terror machen kann und
andererseits die komik dazu die damals
durch die eher intellektuellen macht
geistert und ich denke dass diese
komischen ganz wichtiges korrektiv ist
um uns sozusagen zur noch zu behalten
und uns klarzumachen was
verschwörungstheorien sind deswegen
finde ich diesen clip wirklich toll
und er erinnert mich eben an keine
ahnung erzählungen wie das don boscos
von
es wurde eben diese natur um 1900 die
alle möglichen formen von bioterrorismus
der damals auch existierende als von
partner
ich mache das hier geht es sind eben
descent das hat mir eine distanz dame
und regionen
das heißt es hat eine entlarvende
funktion auch in diesem humor ii sieren
denn herr blume das finde ich jetzt
interessant in bezug auf ihre arbeit
weil sie arbeiten ja ganz stark geben
auch entlarvend in bezug auf
verschwörungs mythen einerseits wie
empfinden sie einen solchen clip und
andererseits möchte man schon noch
verstehen was sind sie nur überhaupt für
leute die auf solche mythen anspringen
also dass er tatsächlich hilft also wir
wissen dass zum beispiel von den black
crowes bahn haben viele leute daran
geglaubt dass in einigen agenten wie
quasi außerirdische entweder von bergen
oder oder verkörpern und seitdem ist
darüber die filme gegeben hat wir haben
gemeinden black ist das sozusagen fast
nicht mehr verwendbar ist einfach durch
den bohr herzlich das ziemlich erledigt
genauso iron sky mit nazi flug scheiben
und lage waren auf dem mond deutschland
da sind also man kann durch humor durch
klugem humor solch ein verschwörungs
steht bei sauber das natürlich bei
antisemitismus es schwieriger weil das
sozusagen jedes mal sofort auch in
südafrika geht hier waren jetzt die
verschwörer medien ja die dort gezeigten
können
aber das hilft natürlich man diese mit
diesen heftigen und was wäre
grundsätzlich würden wir haben in der
forschung ist da es sind menschen die
ich selber in ihrer jugend wie ihre
kindheit schlechtere erfahrungen gemacht
haben im durchschnitt autoritäre
charakter für die fühlt sich die welt
schlechter an es fühlt sich an als ein
böser auch daran können dann später
forschungsverbünde anknüpfen und werden
sagen wer könnte sagen wer die bösen
sind ihr könnt ihr sagen werde nicht
davor schützen kann also autoritäre
persönlichkeit davon fällig bildung
schützt nicht in gewissem maße
wir haben auch immer antisemiten
antisemiten mit doktortiteln
das ist also kein absoluter schutz
sondern letztlich geht es da ganz stark
auch um die funktion erheblichen
vertrauen zur welt habe ich ihm
vertrauen zu medien zur institution zum
rechtsstaat wo der glaube ich die ganze
welt
da kommt dann steht das doch an
schauen wir doch mal ein bisschen in die
geschichte zurück konkret auf die zeit
der spanischen grippe 1918 die spanische
grippe 1918 20 forderte mehr opfer als
der erste weltkrieg
es war ein eigentliches killervirus
schulen wurden zu lazaretten umgenutzt
millionen menschen starben oft in den
stunden die erste grippewelle traf die
schweiz im mai 1918 ersten die behörden
die gefahr
was unterscheidet denn die korona krise
im bezug jetzt auf verschwörungs mythen
von eben solchen früheren pandemien
also ich kann sagen aus unserer sicht
ist natürlich dass heute die
möglichkeiten des internets blick
stärker vernetzen und gemeinsame deute
und gemeinsam verschwörungs mieters zu
berichten
einfach enorm gewachsen sind das war
natürlich damals noch nicht der fall
sie haben gehört oder in der schweiz die
schon demokraten war erste irgendwas zu
kontrollieren und damit umzugehen aber
was auch damals schon passiert ist aber
noch mehr dazu wissen aber ist das
praktische viele regionen muss immer von
woanders geachtet haben also wie waren
einige spanische grippe weiter in
anderen französische oder amerikanische
also man hat so wie er heute der korona
die russische gruppe gleichgesinnter
abgewendet man hat auch damals schon
versucht krippe anders planen zu lassen
aber was heute eben dazu kommt ist in
die ganz anderen media möglichkeiten mit
denen sich leute da austauschen und ihre
eigene weltsicht aus pocking also wenn
sie fragen was die heutigen
versorgungsgebieten von den vergangenen
unterscheidet also zu
diesmal ist in pflanzer kein gutes
beispiel weil die grenzer im grunde
genommen wirklich sehr wenig
verschwörung hervorgebracht hat
natürlich auch aber in erster linie was
anderes eine gigantische
solidaritätswelle entscheidet die
jetzigen verschwörungen von früher ich
würde da noch mal anders ankommt was
herr blume schon gesagt hat und zwar ist
es auffallend dass wir keine reale
gewalt also bei verschwörung denke ich
vor allem an die cholera denn die
cholera ist die gewalttätigste aller
solchen die geht in fünf pandemien durch
sein zehnter jahrhunderten mit enormen
verschwörungen und wenn da jemand eine
verschwörung ans tageslicht bringt dann
heißt das immer unruhen gewaltausbrüche
da herrschte sozusagen krieg im umfeld
der revolutionären umtriebe und was wir
heute haben es in verschwörungs vorgänge
die in meinen augen natürlich zu einem
großen teil auch der reproduktions logik
der medien geschuldet sind das sind
einfach vorgänger die medien sind auf
klicks angewiesen um selbst am leben zu
bleiben speziell die sozialen medien
führt dazu dass das virtuelle phänomene
sind aber ich sehe mich natürlich gibt
es irgendwo mal keine krawalle
aber es ist überhaupt nicht vergleichbar
mit dem zusammenhang von verschwörungen
und gewalt was wir im 19 jahrhundert
dort auch an davon 19
also beide sagen eigentlich die die
massenmedien tragen ganz viel dazu bei
dass eben verschwörungs mythen wie sie
heute entstehen auch so sich weiter
verbreiten können
ist es denn in der regel er jetzt was
globales wirklich also diese mythen oder
sind die regional kann man sehen dass
sich in keine ahnung deutschland diese
und diese verschwörung smeaton
verbreiten und in den usa eher jene und
solche also lokalisiert sich ganz stark
also ändern ist zum beispiel das müssen
sie das müssen sie kurz erklären dieses
kleinen joel chenal das eigentlich
die weltweite verschwörung im gange ist
von jugend demokraten satanisten die
auch gegen kinderrechte richtet und der
donald trump sei quasi der in zeitlicher
etwa wer werte diese diese verschwörung
zerschlagen und das ist etwas was
sozusagen das impuls angekommen ist
inzwischen auch in deutschland ganz
viele anhänger hat also dafür die
globalisierung statt dem umgekippt aus
der schweiz sah sie keinen prediger der
also verkündet die juden wollen die
weltbevölkerung die zu ihren und das 104
und eine eine bio waffe wenn ich da
jetzt ein polizeichef in der schweiz
wäre würde ich mit dem r anderen
sicherheitsgespräch führen aber hallo
aber auf der anderen seite stimmt nicht
traut hinzu wenn wir das in der
geschichte hatten zwölf und 13 jahren
und während noch fest dann habe das zu
ausschreitungen und totgeburten und
jetzt ist es das altenwerk millionen
klicks im netz aber bisher zumindest ist
nicht gelungen
tatsächlich scheint das heißt trotzte
man muss es ernst nehmen bei den
einzelnen haben die sich radikalisiert
oder kleine gruppen aber im vergleich zu
dem was früher los war wo ganze
gemeinden gemeinden bern oder haben
tatsächlich schon viel besser jetzt ist
die spanische grippe ja gerade mal
irgendwie sowas wie drei generationen
her tötete ca man weiß es nicht ganz
genau 25 bis 50 millionen menschen
und irgendwie speziell bei der bei der
zweiten welle sind ja menschen in die
moore am morgen erkrankt am abend
gestorben das sind bilder des grauens
die man da sieht trotzdem scheinen wir
momentan zu glauben dass wir sowas wird
etwas einmaliges erleben deshalb
erinnern wir uns eigentlich so schlecht
an diese vergangenheit frauke die
spanische grippe heißt in einer
bekannten monographie bevor gotten
pandemic und ist in der tat über ganz
lange zeit sie oft gewesen weil die
quellen spärlich sind und die frage die
die soll ja immer wieder gestellt aber
ist die spanische grippe die zu dem
zeitpunkt des größte und schlimm
müsste solch ein ereignis aller zeiten
war warum ist die eigentlich so durch
unseren tisch gefallen und das lässt
sich als wohl am ehesten durch die
historische umstände erklären man muss
sich einfach sagen das ist das letzte
kriegsjahr das ist das zu dem
zusammenbruch für messtechnik mit sehr
kriegs schlachten und die weltweite
presse war natürlich mit dem
kriegsgeschehen beschäftigt und dann
schon irgendwann auch mit der spanischen
grippe die spanische grippe war so etwas
wie ein neben phänomen in einem in einem
krieg der ja letzten endes in einem
desaster endete dann gab es bereits die
revolutionären unruhen überall in
deutschland und das war jetzt
gleichzeitig zu eis kommen und überall
die krippe ausbricht war etwas was von
den medien zwar thematisiert wurde aber
nicht in dem ausmaß wie heute wo man
sagen kann information folgt dem virus
praktisch im gleichtakt her so schnell
wie das virus erkranken 3000 in china
und gewissens eigentlich schon bevor
live-ticker genau die konkurrenz der
internationalen massenmedien um diesen
massen sensations- artikel corona das
ist ja auch ein sensationssieg lung den
die medien konkurrieren die soko dass
die informationen in einer
hochgeschwindigkeits ständig den globus
durch ein und das gab es 1980 also unter
anderem eben weil die schrecken des
ersten weltkriegs alles überlagerten
mehr ist es noch etwas interessantes
aufgefallen in der letzten zeit
kursierten ja viele bilder von ärzten in
vollmontur also komplett quasi verhüllt
den an führungs- und schluss zeichnung
da kam mir diese dr schnabel in rom pest
bilder in den sinn wenn man diese jetzt
gegenüber stellt diese zwei bilder dann
die scheinen sich ja sehr ähnlich zu
sein
kann man das als rüstung gegen die natur
verstehen wie lesen sie das also
zunächst mal muss man glaube ich
unterscheiden zwischen dem faktum diese
schutzausrüstungen die zu jeweiligen
zeiten ziemlich genau den medizinischen
konzepten entsprochen haben die
verhüllung ist es entspricht der
vorstellung
das sind giftige dünnste die von den
teststädten aber auch von krieg
praktischen konstellationen hier rühren
und denen man entgegenwirken kann indem
man in diesen schnabel kräuter und
schwämme mit essig reihen tut die
essenzen ausstoßen so dass man den
pesthauch von dem eben die rede ist
nicht einatmen muss gleichzeitig hat man
natürlich schon eine ahnung von
ansteckungen bei der pest arzt hatten
stab in der hand behält den infizierten
fern und er hat gläsernen also ist das
gut angepasst und genauso gut angepasst
sind ja die schutzanzüge die wir heute
an haben weil wir der meinung sind dass
ein virus 43 fehlt also alles ist gut
angepasst was ich auffällig finde ist
der bedarf nach abbildung nicht nur
zirkuliert im 17 jahrhundert überall
dieser kupferstich des doktor schnabel
heute in medien auf macht und über
corona ließ dann werden wir praktisch
überschüttet mit diesen bildern von den
wissenschaftern und da denke ich
wiederum an die bakteriologische an den
paradigmenwechsel 1880 da gab es das
auch der wurden bakteriologen als
kreuzritter auf dem pferd die die hydra
der tuberkulose welt kaputt machen hält
mir kommt es vor als ob dieser abbildung
zu wahren
etwas von inszenierung des
wissenschaftlers als helden der
gegenwart also dann wirklich was
natürlich auch bei uns gehalten sehr gut
hinwegtäuscht dass ist was damit
verteilt wird ist ein universeller
machbarkeits glaube und zwar bezeichnete
weise immer in den momenten wo man das
den magic bullet was man braucht
eigentlich nicht wir haben keine impfung
und um 1890 gab es kein medizin gegen
rose und die wissenschaftler erscheinen
aber als helden der machbarkeit ist es
so auch zu erklären dass diese
venezianischen karnevalsmasken die auch
so mit seinem schnabel sind also
anleihen an diese dr schnabel verhüllung
dass dieser einen karneval eintritt
gefunden haben
das ist eine sehr gute frage die man
eigentlich ein kunsthistoriker stellen
muss also dass
sie können dann bestimmt auch
beantworten das macht dass solche masken
gar nicht mal eintritt gefunden hat
natürlich was mit der commedia dell'arte
zu tun die im grunde genommen das
tropische arsenal für die ozeanischen
masken vorgibt und wenn man sich fragt
wer in der comedia dell'arte das ist
sozusagen ein laien stegreif theater was
im 17 jahrhundert in venedig besonders
kursierte wenn man sich frägt was das
fan figuren arsenal ist dann sind das
figuren die diese vanitas vorstellung
auch des spätbarock stellen leben tod
liebe sexualität und dass da der pest
doktor der natürlich den tod und die
vanitas verkommen
zusätzlich auch eine methodische figur
der pest doktor ist keine soziale
angesehenen hoch stehende figur dass der
in dieses typische figuren arsenal
einwandert ist nicht allzu erstaunlich
spannend ich möchte weiter gehen im
nämlich zu verschiedenen
erklärungsmustern jetzt ist es ja so
dass im alten und neuen testament
epidemien immer wieder als strafe gottes
auftreten aber auch aktuell der russisch
orthodoxe erzbischof von von berlin sid
des corona virus als strafe gottes
nämlich für die transsexualität und
sterbehilfe also als strafe für den
lebenswandel den momentanen ist es also
weiterhin ein gängiges erklärungsmuster
blumen ja also es gibt es also eine
afrika zum beispiel in diesem bereich
gesagt das ist nicht der grund dass
bedenken besten man kann selbst dann
solche deutschland dann auch immer
wieder autoritäre persönlichkeit suchen
dass das mal wieder abzuwälzen
die anderen sind schuld die gerieten und
die westlichen die homosexuellen oder
wasser und damit sozusagen auch mirja
das abzuleiten und zu sagen wenn dieses
verhalten abschaltet dann wird gott auf
die gäste wo die krankheit verschwinden
lassen
wenn dann ist das sozusagen hält
drohbotschaft wir haben auf gott sei
dank geht natürlich in der mehrheit dass
man sagt nein da geht es nicht um das
gott strafen will sondern da geht es
darum dass die verhältst du dich bist du
für deinen nächsten
solidarität ist vernünftig das heißt man
sieht es so wie es gute und schlechte
wissenschaftliche theorien gibt so gibt
es eben gute und schlechte mythen und
deswegen ist es auch einfach wichtig
darüber nachzudenken tun dass -sendung
und sich auch selber zu fragen was ist
der richtige umgang damit
ich würde so zuzuspitzen was angst
verstärkt oder was sogar hass auf andere
menschen verstärkt dann in einer
situation von was ich interessant finde
ist der einfluss eben von von pandemien
oder auch naturkatastrophen auf die
ganzen ganze glaubenspraxis ich denke da
beispielsweise reden an das erdbeben von
lissabon jetzt eine naturkatastrophe
aber theoretisch auch die die spanische
grippe was haben die genau für
auswirkungen gehabt auf die weltbilder
und auf die glaubenspraxis der menschen
also ich würde sagen wir haben große
unterschiede also lissabon zum beispiel
tatsächlich damit weitere
erschütterungen nach sich gezogen
während jetzt die spanische grippe das
alles so gäste liegen die geschichte
eingegangen ist also die frage sozusagen
wie dass leute die das das für die
gesellschaft verstehbar machen die
praktisch immer auch umstritten wir
haben jetzt die situation dass zum
beispiel der amerikanische präsident
versucht die schuld an die werbung
abzuschieben und zusammenkürzen die
gelder und umgekehrt aber wiederum
verlieren möchte dass die gouverneure
sagen der präsident versagt also auch
hier viele deutungen sind eigentlich
machtkämpfe und dann ist natürlich so
dass dann automatisch eines nicht
durchsetzt sondern das sind wir alle
daran beteiligt ich finde als mündige
bürger ist dass er offenbar aufgabe
dafür dann eben sagen diese deutung die
kann ich mittragen und diese deutung die
lasse ich nicht zu also wenn ich zum
beispiel mit sagen würde
das geht auf menschen mit dunkler
hautfarbe zurückwerfen china haben
deswegen ist rassismus auf
dann hoffe ich dass die mehrheit der
menschen 50 zu sagen nein
diese deutung tragen wenig gekämpft wird
es immer sein dann wird es immer
marien in bezug auf die glaubenspraxis
und die veränderungen von pandemien frau
kennen
was sagen sie dazu jetzt aktuell oder
also ich kann am besten was natürlich in
der vergangenheit bei tragen
die pest wird immer so als also
emblematisch für die pest scheint die
pest von 1948 zu sein weil jeder weiß
dass das praktisch ein jüdischer genozid
war er erster dass diese jüdischen
programme hunderte von gemeinden in
deutschland und frankreich und in der
schweiz ausgelöst haben und das ist so
das bild was durch geist etwas weniger
bekannt ist ist dass das einzigen
schweren jüdischen pogrome waren bei 10
148 während die schwarzen tod ist und
danach wird die beste endemisch und
geistert in weiteren großen pandemischen
wellen durch europa ende des vierzehnten
jahrhundert 15 jahrhundert im
sechzehnten jahrhundert im siebzehnten
jahrhunderten dass es dann keine
programme mehr gibt antijüdischen
pogrome mehr gibt sondern ganz im
gegenteil das dann durch diese
universelle und total alternativlose
erklärung dass es gottes strafe für sind
auf das leben für ein christliches leben
für den verlust von caritas das da
offensichtlich ein wandel eingesetzt und
der verlust von christlicher
nächstenliebe der in 1380 in allen
schafft auch wieder einsetzt mit einer
kollektiven frömmigkeit die ganz
bestimmte rituelle und sehr große
rituelle ausmaße annimmt so dass bei
passt wellen zunächst mal machen
prozessionen und festgelegte liturgien
und massen beete veranstaltet werden
weil man gottes zu besänftigen muss und
wenn die besten vorbei ist dann gibt es
religiöse heute feiern was ich das schön
finde da werden dann festlich die
quarantäne vierten entlassen und es
werden zum beispiel gebäude errichtet
zum dank an gott
denn tore und lisa luther in venedig und
die fest säule in wien das im wallis
male der dankbarkeit die
zusammengenommen mit dieser kollektiven
frömmigkeit natürlich einen hoch
integrativen charakter hatten also
dieser gedanke die pest streut hass und
zerstört sicher in 48 ganz im
vordergrund und in den folgenden bilden
setzt eine so immense kollektive
freundlichkeit ein die jeweils muss er
sich vorstellen städte betrifft also die
ganze stadt war auf den füßen in weißen
bücher kleider und hat auch gottes erst
bit und dann dankgottesdienst gefeiert
wurden pest heilige herumgetragen dann
sprach man von wundern und das hat
natürlich stadt kollektive integriert
und dieser gedanke der dankbarkeit wenn
die pest vorbei ist ist natürlich
eingang ein gedanke eines gütigen und
gnädigen gottes und ich denke dass habt
die glaubenspraxis verändert und zwar in
hinblick auf eine sehr stark integrative
praktisch jetzt was man aber auch
beobachtet ist ja dass solche pandemien
solche ende zeitlichen vorstellungen
wieder hervorrufen also dass man eben
nicht quasi erwartet bis die pest vorbei
ist und dass man glaubt das sind jetzt
vor zeichen dafür dass die welt bald zu
ende geht das haben sie herr blume ja
auch zuvor schon angesprochen
in bezug eben auch dass freitags for
future als das 666 des johannes der
johannes apokalypse also die ja wirklich
die die endzeit naht gelesen wird was
hat es damit auf sich
ja wenn menschen dann eben dieser angst
stecken und immer verschwörungs angst
stellen wenn es natürlich wahnsinnig
berührt denn dann eine rettungs
botschaft kommt und hier haben wir jetzt
tatsächlich im februar einen kunst
nennen sich selber auch juristen und das
mit auch schon von einer abwegig alten
säcken bewegung an
ich würde da auch zocken einfach
zustimmen dass wir immer wieder auf
religions- produktive zeit in berlin
haben wollt ende war sie auch neue wenn
diese bewegungen standen sich dass ich
hier allerdings sehe ist dass das
apokalyptische endzeit lichdi er
geschafft ist die leute rechnen damit
dass jetzt jeden moment warten
die entschlackt stattfinden kann und es
wird spannend sein was dann passiert
wenn das nicht
die leute weil sie merken der todkranke
ist gar nicht klar
dieses vor einer weltweiten verschwörung
nach dem was wir bisher erlebt haben
wird es so sein dass ich wahrscheinlich
in all still zurückzieht
ein anderer teil wird das neue verschoss
erzählungen integrierung bedanken das
ist in die ns zeit aufgehalten worden
aber da ist schon der nächste vermute
aber auch dass er in den kleinen teil
psychosen oder eben auf gewalt erleben
werden wir haben in deutschland die
ersten fälle und flüssigen bei allem
optimismus würde ich eben auch sagen
müssen wir das auch gewaltbereitschaft
im blick behalten
da wird es sicherlich einige wenige
ausreißer jetzt aber einzelfälle nicht
mehr wirken
jetzt haben wir viel über verschwörungs
mythen oder verschwörungstheoretiker wie
man auch immer sie nennen möchte geredet
jetzt sind aber trotzdem natürlich auch
so dass verschiedene
religionsgemeinschaften auch
unterschiedliche art und weisen haben
wie sie damit umgehen zum beispiel
fasten gegen das virus gerade personal
hat das hat das gemacht in brasilien
dann gibt es die idee dass man
meditieren könnte um den ganzen planeten
zu desinfizieren das sind so ein
bisschen esoterische gemeinschaften oder
dann leute die die die beten gegen das
virus oder man glaubt überhaupt man
braucht gar keinen schutz gegen das
virus weil man selber schon geschützt
ist ja machen dass gläubige besser als
verschwörungstheoretiker ja also ich
würde sagen das kommt dann auch immer
darauf an dass wir jetzt immer sagt wir
machen jetzt ein online gottesdienste
und bieten gemeinsam mit und haben die
vorschriften flüge antwort 15 verbot
alle und wir sind ja in jesus luz
geschaltet oder damit zb eine ganz klare
ansichten gehabt im dom also der liga
statt
auch die geistlichkeit nicht zugeben
wollte dass ich dort der virus dann
ausgebreitet
auch hier also
ein aufgeklärter vernünftiger glaube wer
kann da eine hilfe um stütze sein ein
fundamentalistischer touristischer
glaube er meint wenn ich selber die
richtigen magischen worte oder die
richtigen ideen zur hand habe kann mir
nichts da kann sich dann natürlich auch
negativ
dazu würde ich gerne etwas sagen was ihm
genau das gleiche horn bläst eine
erfahrung die wir aus den fruehen best
schriften aus der wirklich großen patch
literatur des 14 jahrhundert zu sehen
können aber auch des 16 jahrhunderts
also komplett denke ich an boccaccio und
an die förde sind die beiden großen best
schriften der frühen neuzeit was man
daraus lernt ist das im vordergrund
eigentlich nicht so sehr die hre stehen
sondern die gewalt im alltag die
verrohung der gesellschaft derzeit als
soziale bindungen und das fängt in
familie an die eltern verlassen die
kinder ehepartner verlassen einander die
nachbarn helfen einander nicht mehr die
ärzte lassen die patienten im stich und
zuallererst lässt die regierung alle im
stich und haut ab
das ist sozusagen der frühneuzeitlichen
und spätmittelalter in gstaad in der
pest und die chronisten bahnen immer
davor dass sie sagen und das ist eine
nationale warnung und überhaupt keine
spirituelle dass dieser diese basis
solidarität innerhalb der enge soziale
micro sozialen bindungen die zerfällt
und die gibt raum für kriminalität für
sexuelle verrohung also in die neuzeit
war es war als gegen sexuelle gewalt
gegen frauen also es kommt zu einer
bestia lisi rung der gesellschaft und
ich denke gebete sind natürlich sinnvoll
und ein rat den sie dann ist auch die
selbst in dieser situation
ich würde das gleiche konkret nicht
beide solidarität in voller wie die
irgendwie desinfizieren wollen weil ich
glaube wir müssen wirklich da ansetzen
wo die wirklichkeit von solche ist sie
beobachte ich auch in meinem dorf
einfach mangel soll
realität und lege menschen die nicht
verstehen dass man ausweicht dieses was
natürlich auch sehr stark ist die
solidarität ich glaube das gebet für
solidarität und für den erhalt von mikro
sozialen bindungen wäre es wesentlich
ist dass mit rationalität
ich kann das nicht vereinbar bitte ich
kann da vielleicht sagen also meine frau
ist muslimin
ich bin christ und komme aus einer nicht
religiösen familie und das ist dann auch
ganz interessant ist auch die rückkehr
nicht wo man daten doch merkt das kann
auch tatsächlich auch einen zusammen das
macht dann eben kein berufsbild marita
doch im gleichen gott und übrigens auch
erklärtes dann vielleicht also den
zugang ich bin mit einem sehr
wissenschaftlichen weltbild aufgewachsen
aber klar die revolution schimmel alessi
das heißt dass religiöse und spirituelle
kam dann eher einfach dazu und dadurch
einmal dann kriegst auch nicht in
widerspruch wenn jetzt jemand einen
fundamentalistischen glauben hat und
glaubt wie wissenschaft gedroht die ins
herz der möchte ich meinen glauben
kaputt machen wird er unter umständen
natürlich mit der gleichen situation
ganz anders umgehen und vielleicht zum
beispiel daniel das gebet gegen jemand
verrichten oder dieser verschwörung
geschützt zu werden
ich möchte ein stichwort von ihnen
aufnehmen frau king von zuvor mit der
verrohung man hat ja eben des corona
virus auch als das chinesische virus
bezeichnet also das fremde das in uns
eindringt vor dem man sich schützen muss
ich frage mich brechen hier wieder uhr
muster von xenophobie auch weil man hat
ja auch bei im spiegel dass das
titelbild made in china zum beispiel das
polarisiert schon eine ganz genaue
richtung also erstens ist das natürlich
immer ende oder bei vielen epidemien in
der geschichte so gewesen das ist eine
frage der perspektive ist und das fremde
ist dann die denominationen das heißt
noch gar nicht unbedingt dass diese
zuschreibung ist sie so verließ je nach
bremen aus welcher perspektive man drauf
geschaut wird man ab und sind es die
neapolitaner kommt oder die franzosen
krankheit aber weil man sich gefragt hat
ob der kaiser nach neapel
gegangen ist um mit seinem sollte hier
die neapolitaner einzelne ob der denn
die krankheit über europa gestreut hat
oder ob es mehr bekommen das war nicht
unbedingt mit schon zuschreibungen
verknüpfen
grundsätzlich ist schon so dass das
fremde die solche bringt und dass man
tendenziell also nicht nur harmlos
benennt sondern auch benennen unschuld
zuschreibung miteinander verknüpft ist
das ist wiederum in der cholera sehr
deutlich aber da gibt es verschwörung
von oben und von unten also es gibt die
von und von oben das heißt es sind die
autoritäten die natürlichen schuldigen
suchen um auf diese art und weise auch
garantien maßnahmen besser durchzusetzen
und man muss ganz klar sagen dass diese
xenophobie immer autoritäts staatlichen
maßnahmen dient natürlich gibt es in den
cholera wellen immer aggression von oben
xenophobie von oben gegen migranten aus
dem osten es gibt große migrations auf
gegen händler
vereinzelt übrigens nur gegen juden
dominanter am ende des neunzehnten
jahrhunderts in amerika gegen türkische
einwanderer gibt es ein ganz berühmtes
satirische abbildung aus der magazin wo
die cola als skelett auf dem buch spielt
eines einwanderer sitzt schiff sitzt und
die hat einen hut auf
da ist es das ist eine art von
einwanderer den wir nicht wollen
wird also die türkische
migrationsbevölkerung direkt mit dem tod
identifiziert und das ist natürlich
schon eine massive verunglimpfung
also wie gesagt sind alles musste die
man nach der pest am ehesten in der
cholera zeit sehen kann gibt es denn
antworten darauf weshalb die xenophobie
an solchen nachhaltiges muster in
unserem denken ist und eben auch in für
die ganze zuschreibung grundsätzlich ist
es so dass menschen in gefahr
so kann bei gleichen suchen und das
fremd wird es andere sind dann
tendenziell abgestoßen
und natürlich kann ich dann angst auch
auf jetzt vergeben hat investoren wenig
zb dann ist es natürlich praktisch
monaten auf dem zeigen kann wo ich
wieder auf mein team ist das natürlich
schon wiederkehrendes motiv
wenn es dann länger anhält auch das
reguliert haben sie es aber auch nach
dem wenden also bis etwa 30 fremd wird
die rettet das kind im stich dass du
auch das hat mich natürlich und ich
glaube das spielen wir auch alle hin wir
gerade dann aufwändig dass solche fragen
erleben dass man ins getriebe erst mal
versucht mit dem menschen werden geiseln
zusammenzurücken und menschenleer fern
waren die verschwinden dann auch
vielleicht erst mal als bei wahrnehmung
was ganz spannend ist und was der
wissenschaften das heißt ich kann heute
vorüber sind ja auch nur in meine arbeit
durch eine veranstaltung machen kann
haben wir den ford kraft gesetzt und
sind über die wahnsinnig überrascht wie
viele leute sich da interessieren damit
auseinandersetzen
und ja ich nehme ja schon viel viel mehr
als wir in veranstaltung bekommen hätten
sagen wir jetzt nicht die zeit dafür
setzen sich natürlich etwas was man sich
wundern können sie sind ja auch experte
für antisemitismus und da also
beauftragte baden württemberg und man
fragt sich weshalb sind es immer wieder
die juden die in dieser in dieser ganzen
auf solchen geschichte immer wieder als
die beschuldigten gelten gibt es einen
gibt eine erklärung dafür
ja also dass das häufigste nichts
zuständig ist nämlich ergebnisse glauben
sie wären der rasse dass juden und
araber wurden sprachgruppe aber in der
jüdischen tradition selber an der
chamber ist tatsächlich der erste der
eine schule gegründet hat neuhaus die
alphabetisch beispiel jesus
zwölfjähriger er von seinen eltern in
temple wiedergefunden wird vor drei
tagen den schriftgelehrten diskutiert
hat der sohn eines zimmermanns kann
lesen und schreiben und das judentum und
zwar die erste tief und bildungs
religion der welt eine komische reto
berra oder 304.000 achten buchstaben
keinen er keine weniger und damit wird
das judentum im gegenzug zu den
der sammelt von 30 ist und für die
gruppe der malerei abgewertet wird das
heißt weniger chlor und die wir sind
diesem foul oder so wird im
antisemitismus für das jupa aufgewertet
um die sind schlauer
die sind aber besonders die können alles
kontrollieren und das macht das ganze
natürlich schon gefährlich um antisemit
fühlt sich verschwörungen bedroht selbst
wenn er gar keine juden kennt wir haben
in baden württemberg solche reichs
bürger ja auch ein ganz gutes afrika
existiert gar nicht besonders eine
jüdische verschwörung und die angela
merkel war auch die und das macht den
eigentlich semitismus gefährt also
bildung durch die alphabetisierung und
natürlich waren juden juden unterarm
ernst die stark vertreten
und das bezieht sich das durch in
deutschland das paul-ehrlich-institut
zum beispiel des kreis endlich die
gefolgschaft
das waren unter einem biologischen
virologe natürlich der unglaubliches
geleistet aber der zweifel nicht in den
adelstand erhoben wurden jude war und
hinter dem antisemitismus auch wir
kommen langsam gegen ende der sendung
ich möchte noch klären
menschen glauben ja an jede menge
entitäten oder oder prozesse geben
wissenschaftlich nicht beweisbar oder
oder eher erklärbar sind wo liegt denn
jetzt eigentlich genau der unterschied
zwischen verschwörungs glauben und
anderen glauben blume also im
unglaublich erscheint eine gute
gottesglaube gebauten und so weiter das
ist auch ein höheres wesen das nicht
behütet und sieht wenn ich ja der glaube
habe dass diese höhere das böse ist eine
ein glas sekt oder 10 ist in lumina dann
erweckt dass er sich ganz andere
assoziationen als man kann sagen dass
sozusagen im selten sehr
übermenschlichen wesen halten
die sind ja nicht neutral die könnten
lieb sein league wird im bild zu sein
die können rasch erfolg sei wohlmeinend
sagt bassist sich ganz wiederum auf
meine erfahrungen meinen finden aus
deswegen große appell einfach auch
kuchen sowie jedoch darauf achten
und visionären afrika zum zu nehmen
machte keinen unterschied welche mythen
gehen unsere köpfe lassen und im
zweifelsfall sollte natürlich nicht
mögen hass und angst zu drücken lassen
king ich glaube sie wollten zuvor auch
noch etwas sagen ja ich würde es aber
jetzt eigentlich schon fast bis hin zu
spät ich wollte korrigieren dass es
historisch gesehen nicht über die juden
sind
das trifft den 19 jahrhundert einfach
nicht zu und das hat auch was mit der
demo phobie zu tun die damals zum
wissenschaftlichen stand erst ab und
raste anthropologie gehört das fängt mit
kant und blumenbach aber dann gibt es
großen rasse anthropologen im 19
jahrhundert und die xenophobie richtet
sich da zunächst mal gegen schwaab die
einfach auf dem standpunkt von affen
waren und gegen ende des jahrhunderts
als die erreger theorie einsetzt der wir
heute noch sozusagen als causales
prinzip anhängen da sind es farbige und
zwar die schmutzigen inder weil aus
indien kommt der cholera bazillus also
mir ist wäre es wichtig dass man ein
bisschen dieses bild korrigiert es sind
immer die juden das ist nämlich so nicht
wahr und es gibt ja auch sehr viel
xenophobie gegen farbige
bevölkerungsgruppen und das hat durchaus
auch seine wurzeln im 19 jahrhundert und
außerdem auch gegen slawen gegen polen
also der rassismus blüte wirklich mit
einer vollkommen mit ungebremsten
schamlos und die großen epidemien wurden
immer jemandem der typus den slawen und
die cholera den indern wurde immer
irgendjemanden angehängt so dass ich
glaube auch eine warnung für heute man
das ein bisschen im auge behalten dass
man immer dazu neigt solche hat
irgendeinen rasse namen abgesehen dass
der menschlichen rassen gibt sondern wir
eine rasse sind und uns intern auf
spalten kann man sagen solche klebt
immer an irgendeiner nähe und das sind
zuschreibungen die die polarisierungen
wahnsinnig fördern leuchten polarisiert
vor davon geredet haben das ist
eigentlich um die unmittelbaren
kollektiven bindungen geht die mikro
sozialen
und auch die solidarität mit der
bevölkerung dann finde ich es richtig
dass im kopf zu halten dass man dass
diese irrationalen gedanken eigentlich
ablehnen sollte was ich mache also gar
nicht dabei da noch mal durch rassismus
ja wenn ich da diese kopien schmutzig
diese gruppe trinken oder eben der
verschwörungs mythos wo es heißt die
kontrollieren alles also diese das ist
ja auch gerade geschieht in
rassistischen werden die gruppen
abgewertet ein verschwörungs drives sind
besonders schlau und da ist es dann
tatsächlich was ist ihr verschwörungs
der vorwurf der weltverschwörung de
richtet sich immer wieder mit rassismus
richtet sich in unterschiedliche und was
immer auch stimmt es hat bis 30 nie
gelungen auch nur zu definieren wie
viele rassen ist dann ebenso 1 3 18 217
ganz es ist überhaupt nicht möglich weil
wir natürlich bestandteil einer
menschheit sind es gibt unterschiede
geben zb youtube anschauen haben sich in
der jugend aller hautfarben und deswegen
ist tatsächlich rassismus hat keinen
halt in der wirklichkeit hier sind ein
mensch eine bunte welt aber eben ein
gemeinschaften
ich möchte jetzt schon zum schluss frage
kommen damit wir auch schön aufhören
können für jeden von ihnen was hat denn
oder hat denn eine solche solche eben
auch etwas gutes rocken sie haben es
schon angedeutet zu beginn was mir jetzt
bei der korona solche wirklich auffällt
als die story ist mit welchem
verantwortungsbewusstsein wir in
europäischen staaten leben dürfen wurde
public gedanke nicht noch hoch
entwickelt sondern so tief verankert ist
dass die solchen kontrolle die fürsorge
des staates eine ganz ganz neue
erfindung ist dass die für so hat es für
uns als bevölkerung als gesellschaft so
weit geht dass wir nah gut einige
maßnahmen in kauf nehmen müssen
die sich fatal sind und jeden einzelnen
betreffen
trotzdem es verantwortungsträger gibt
die tag und nacht arbeiten und sie
schaffte innerhalb von vier wochen die
sie ab
die kurve die exponentiell an stieg und
drohte die gesamte bevölkerung zu töten
diese kurve zum abflachen bringen dafür
sorgen dass die spezielle funktionieren
dafür sorgen dass wieder alle anrecht
auf eine luxus medizin haben also ich
bin schier überwältigend ich über dieses
ausmaß von raths formaler solchen
kontrolle von zusammenarbeit der
europäischen regierungen historiker
denkt man sich gut dass wir jetzt leben
herr blum mit ganz kurz also ich finde
gut dass menschen nachdenken zum
beispiel diese sendung und ich hoffe
dass wir gestalten gemeinsam ganz
herzlichen dank ihnen beiden schön dass
sie dabei waren
nächste woche sehen sie an dieser stelle
eine interreligiöse feier aus dem haus
der religionen in bern in der
sternstunde philosophie gibt es nun eine
einführung in die logik mit anweisungen
wie man in zeiten von verschwörungs
mieten einen klaren kopf bewahren kann
menschen sonntag und bleiben sie
kritisch
[Musik]